any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
all right james we are live and we are
recording
we are also live and we are here to
discuss this that i got
multiple copies of in the mail thanks to
you i'm going to get my own
very own copy from amazon.com
next week as we get uh everything dialed
in for the launch
of i think is your best book uh i've
read them all i've read them all and
i've
i've talked about them all i've bought
them all for my uh for my friends
in the whole james aldrich shelf on your
in your house i do and actually the the
whole library
here at ucsd has been converted to the
altitude wing
we uh when you didn't have to donate
that much that first 250 million
those 25 million i had
i had to beat out jim simons but
fortunately the price of bitcoin went up
so
yeah that's right okay because this book
is nothing
if not a book about experiments and i am
an experimental physicist
as james knows we're deep involved in an
experiment
in uh in exploring the universe in its
many different forms exploring the
biggest topics
uh under the multiverse the the
existence of god
or the lack thereof the existence of
other universes or lack thereof
and now we're talking about something a
little bit more practical than those
maybe
how you can exceed how you can as the
subtitle says
use ten thousand experiments to
reach surprising goals and other
surprising advice for reaching your
goals
and like all of james book this book
well you got to read it with a box of
kleenex right james
you're always writing with in mind that
if the reader's not in tears
of of joy pain and self
growth uh you you didn't do your job
right
yeah i mean the thing about getting good
at something
that is worth getting good at it it's
going to suck
most of the time like let's say let's
say you're trying to
win the nobel prize in physics a subject
you know a lot about
uh you love physics you
you you love doing the experiments you
love pursuing the dream you love asking
the questions like where where how did
the universe begin
and yet pursuing a dream most of the
time
sucks because that's that's the reason
why it's a dream most people can't do it
most people
uh you know along the way you suffer
failure
you suffer loss you so you you you try
different experiments and they don't
work out let's say you want to be a
professional tennis player as you're
rising up through the ranks
you're going to start losing more than
you ever have as a kid you're going to
start playing tournaments and you're
going to start losing
so most of the time there's there's
struggle
people think oh i'm going to pursue my
dream and then i'll be happy i'm going
to find my passion and then i'll be
happy
finding your passion is not happiness
but but
achieving mastery it's something being
in the top one percent of your field and
monetizing it
does feel incredibly good but along the
way there's a lot of pain
yeah i i talked to you about this once
before how
you know let's say you're trying to lose
weight as i am continually in this
battle although with your help and and
some of the tips and
about physicality i was able to drop
five pounds uh from my double chin to my
ass
and i do thank you for that uh because
those tips to take care of your physical
body
uh are really running through my mind at
all times i'm like i could be successful
financially maybe i could be successful
as a professor maybe
but if you don't have a body if you
don't have health you know that's the
the highest form
of wealth and to me looking at it as an
experiment i start to think well what if
i
get one percent better a day because you
know i noted this when i started reading
the book
that the ultimate way to skip the line
is to
master control over time and space and
einstein was renowned
for his gedunken experiments which you
speak fluent german i know that
uh i know your favorite word in uh in
german language as
is mine is krankavagen
do you know what the crank of wagon is
james no
what does that mean it's an ambulance so
you know there's a lot of uh there's a
lot of uh
german words i believe they're german in
in the chess world so like
zugsvang is you know a situation where
your opponent
can't make any move or he'll lose right
there's nowhere to go but
but down and uh i do uh i do think about
that
quite often but in terms of of you know
these experiments ge duncan experiments
einstein did 10 000 experiments he was
not an experimental physicist he was a
mind physicist he was a theoretical
physicist
he was a jewish physicist the germans
considered him too jewish to
do by doing theoretical physics was not
manly and was not aryan
and so they actually forbid german uh
jews who were doing this type of
theoretical physics
from winning the nobel prize actually
this was a a big constraint on them
but i started thinking about well these
ten thousand hours uh that you talk
about they can compound
and in the compounding of ten thousand
by the way the square root of ten
thousand james
hundred hundred so one hund one over a
hundred is one percent
so get one percent better every day and
you can compound
and by the end of the year you'll be 37
times better right
so but i started thinking what if i want
to lose one percent of my weight
you know every day or something like
that let's say you want to lose to lose
10 pounds
and you want to do it one percent a day
uh and so i started thinking well you
know what is that like
and if you go through the math it turns
out as you know every time you double
something
in the exponential growth in this hockey
stick curve you add
everything that came before to it in
other words when you go from two to four
you're adding you know two plus one plus
one
before and you get four so if you're
going to lose 10 pounds in a year
that last that first five pounds is
going to take you basically half a year
the first you know 2.5 pounds is going
to take you three months
uh and the first you know uh the first
one and a half pounds or 1.25 pounds
that's going to take you 30 to 40 days
and i started thinking like you could
drink like a soda and gain one pound so
how do you keep your resiliency up
during this very slow phase and the
initial ascent up the exponential that
is the one percent growth rule
i mean it's hard to quantify it so much
like that like how you just did with
weight but like
because just the same way like what does
it mean to get one percent better
at business every day what does it mean
to get one percent better at tennis
every day
but the whole idea is every day
you need to be thinking in terms of you
know like we were talking last week
about the nature of science you need to
ask
questions what don't
[Music]
and then put in most people
don't try to improve every day they're
happy they get their phd in physics say
or they
get a rank in tennis that they're happy
with and then they just play the game or
they just
you know become a teacher and and do
their work but
by doing by asking what you don't know
and what
and where you're weak you could start
doing experiments
to to learn things that maybe nobody
knows so for instance
in physics you can ask well nobody knows
really how the universe began why don't
they know
because we don't know really what
happened before uh the cosmic background
radiation
existed so what are our experiments to
explore that more
and the nature of experiments is that
nobody
has done it before see that everybody
thinks the ten thousand hour rule
is the fastest way to mastery but it's
not it's actually the slowest way
because the ten thousand hour rule
mostly involves repetition and then
feedback from a coach and then
repetition again and then feedback from
a coach
and so on and the nature of experiments
is
let's say you're trying to get better at
tennis oh maybe today
or let's say you're trying to get better
at um
stand-up comedy which is when i was
thinking a lot about this ten thousand
hour role
well okay how about if i do comedy on
i'm gonna do an experiment i'm gonna do
stand-up comedy on a subway
because the audience is guaranteed to be
a hostile audience
and you're gonna have to be very tight
on your punch lines
to get people to laugh at all and you're
gonna have to get used to very
uncomfortable situations
so now this is a scenario where
probably no other comedian is really
doing this on their path to learning
they kind of do the same
thing every day and and they hope that
putting in the 10 000 hours will make
them better
but by doing an experiment you leapfrog
what everybody else knows you put
yourself in a difficult situation
and you experiment with with ways to do
better in that difficult situation
and that instantly that one experiment
could be worth
100 hours could be worth 500 hours in in
the context of the 10
000 hour roll and it's always it's
always great at any given point i might
have five or six
experiments going on in in the different
areas that i'm interested in because i
want to get better at
a lot of different things i'm passionate
about a lot of different things
right and i i can you know i'm reading
this book through the lens of a
physicist of a scientist of an
experimental physicist
and always with this image of a theorist
albert einstein in my mind
and i couldn't help but think of this a
quote from the most famous experiment
that
really kicked off the era of relativity
that we now enjoy and that einstein
benefited so much from he said
of the michelson-morley experiment which
shout out to case western reserve
university
carnegie mellon's bitter arch rival to
the west
uh uh my alma mater uh it was done there
and this was the experiment that
falsified the concept of the ether
and we'll talk about that in a second
but einstein called this experiment he
said if this experiment
had not brought us into serious
embarrassment
no one would have regarded the
relativity theory as halfway baked
in other words the the fact that an
experiment can be embarrassing
is is probative and i like the fact that
you say
you shouldn't do an experiment unless
you could be embarrassed so talk about
that talk about the stakes the skin in
the game
as your buddy in tele calls it uh what
about that that
is so engendering of quality uh
experimentation
for benefit that ultimately leads to as
einstein called it redemption
right well let's say let's say you want
to be
an entrepreneur or let's say you want to
be a writer you have
writing is a good example you have to do
and physics also is a good example
you have to experiment with things that
nobody has ever done before
part of the reasons you might not know
something is because nobody knows it
so if i write an article that somebody
else has basically written before
then that's not interesting somebody
will read the article in my article and
say oh i
already read that so and so as brian
keating has already written about this
so
i don't need to read james's version so
with writing and any kind of art or any
kind of science
you always have to say what is
interesting to me
that i can't read anywhere else so that
by nature is an experiment because you
don't if you write something that no
one's ever written before
uh then it could be the case that no
one's interested i don't i never hit
publish on an article
unless i'm afraid of what people will
think of me
unfortunately a lot of the times people
think
horrible things to me after i write
something but that also shows the
strength of
of your your writing because
what happens when you start doing these
experiments and what happens when you
say i want to get
this is this is the whole reason for the
title skip the line it's not just how to
learn
faster and how to monetize faster but
it's because nobody
wants you to skip the line yeah
if i hey everybody i'm a stand-up
comedian
or i want to be a computer scientist or
whatever
the first thing people are going to say
to me is you can't do that
you need xyz experience you need to have
been doing this for 10 or 15 years you
don't
james don't expect to skip the line
you've got to pay your dues like the
rest of us
right and those things have been said to
me every single time
i've switched passions when i uh became
when i became an
entrepreneur after going to you know
after being an employee at hbo
when i started a hedge fund when i
started podcasting when i started
writing books
when i started doing stand-up comedy
after all this people would always say
you can't do that james you got to spend
you got to do the 10 000 hours
but i don't want to spend 20 years
getting good at something
so the only way a nobody wants you to
skip the line because
they don't want you to change if you if
they tell you you can't do it
they they just they can't do it they
don't want you to
they like you being you the person who's
beneath them in some hierarchy
or that they understand because they
have a mental model that they've sung
cost into and they want to say oh james
is just a podcaster
james is just a stand-up comedian they
don't want to invest the mental calories
to re-evaluate their assessment and
judgment about you that's how powerful
those biases are
right like if if brian keating says hey
i want to do an experiment that will win
the nobel prize
everyone's going to say to you brian
come on you know the odds of winning the
nobel prize only
like so so many hundred people have made
it out of billions
and that's when someone tells you you
can't do something
that's when you should try to do it
because
just the fact that someone is saying
that to you means you're probably
passionate about it
and then what do you do you can't just
do things that every other physicist
done
did you have to you have to think of
what do people not know
what do i don't know that i'm really
curious about and i'm willing to put the
time
and the energy in to do this experiment
and you might start with small
experiments
so i wanted to do an experiment on on
writing in a different format
you know i've been writing for 30 years
and
you know there's there's various formats
you could write in you can write an
article
that's like letters back and forth
between two people that's called the
epistolary form
you can write an article in the second
person and the third person and so on
so i wanted to write in a different
format than i usually write
i didn't want to just write in some
format that someone else has written
in so i i i specifically wanted to write
about
why why was donald trump
tweeting that he wanted to buy greenland
and then the prime minister of denmark
tweeted back it's not for sale first off
i didn't even know you could buy a
country
second i was just fascinated these world
leaders were kind of doing this
weird negotiation on twitter so i did my
research
and i could have just written an article
but instead what i did was
i i did all i wrote it as if it was an
article but i did it as a kickstarter
so i wanted to raise a hundred million
dollars to buy greenland
so that these world leaders can't hog it
all and so i wrote the reasons why
almost like an article but then i had to
come up with all sorts of rewards
you know if people donate a certain
amount they
i would make them an earl or a duke or
make a holiday after them
in greenland or or give them you know
100 acres of land
and uh and that was an experiment not
only in writing because it was a new
format for me an article written in
kickstarter format
but i had never done a kickstarter
project before so it was
that was i learned something brand new
just by doing this article
on kickstarter and i actually started
raising money
yeah and i raised over a thousand
dollars within
minutes and kickstarter shut me down
right and so i
i asked extra why'd you do this and they
said well we don't really believe
you're serious and we we're responsible
for
the credit card fees when we return
people's money so i learned something
new there
so just by doing an experiment i learned
about kickstarter i learned another
format for writing i learned all about
greenland which i never knew anything
about and
that's what experiments do for you plus
you get a story out of it right i'm
doing another experiment right now
people told me you need you have an
obligation to vote and i
said to myself why i always thought
voting was a right
not an obligation you have a right to
vote but you also have a right not to
vote
and people said no no you you can't do
that
you have no voice in policy you you
should have no voice if you don't vote
and i said well there are other ways to
have a voice so i did an experiment
i went to fec.gov which is the website
of the federal elections commission
and the government and if you go there
right now and you search for me
i did all the paperwork and i filed
officially to run as a candidate for
president
in 2024 and now i'm not really that
serious about it anybody can do this
everybody should do it
but now if anyone says to me you should
have no voice in policy i could say well
i'm
i'm running for president so maybe i
should have a voice and
my theory there is there should be more
than one party anyway
and it was interesting to learn how easy
it was to file hundreds of people who
have filed to run for president
and so i learned something new and it
made me also think about the issues in a
different way
yeah so it's a one-way experiment
they sound funny and they sound kind of
weird but
that's the nature of doing thousands of
experiments or hundreds of experiments
even
is that it pushes your knowledge forward
and it gives you stories it gives you
information and
uh but not even not even just you i mean
first of all i want to thank you for
making me the duke of west
aseat which as you know is the fourth
largest
city in greenland i i do enjoy that my
my uh 3 900 no 3069
other residence inhabitants of assyat
which is appropriate name for me uh uh
thank you and all the stewardship you've
done
uh your administration so it sounds like
[ __ ]
uh so so many things to unpack and what
you just said and i can't help but
but related to you know these these
experiences i've had as an experimental
physicist
first of all one of the worst things you
can do is tell somebody
that the science is settled is this is
my claim yes we have evidence yes we
have other things but if the science was
settled when isaac newton
was around you wouldn't have had
einstein who we keep talking about we
will continue to talk about them it's
impossible not to talk about them
uh and feynman used to say richard
feynman was eminent physicist one of
them of the 20th century
used to say science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts and so what does
that mean i thought experts are supposed
to be smart
no experts can be smart uh they have
knowledge they may have wisdom they may
not
but the ultimate thing is if you tell
somebody that you should trust the
experts and rely on the experts
then what you're telling them is that no
further investigation is needed no
further
experiment is needed and what you've
been saying all along about the value of
experiments for
the experimentalist him or herself an
i.e me or you
it actually has a lever effect because
by you doing an experiment that relieves
me if the experiment is repeatable in
principle
i don't have to do that experiment in
other words you don't have to do 10 000
light bulb filaments or whatever we
taught you talk about in the book about
edison
because edison did that now that frees
you up i always tell this to my students
it's kind of depressing but like when
they solve something
and they solve a hugely hard problem in
the lab i'm like
you know mazel tov now you have earned
your ticket
to an even harder problem because all
these
yeah go ahead well you know think about
i'm not a tennis player but for some
reason i use
tennis analogies maybe because the only
person i played in the past 10 years
was my daughter when she was 12 years
old and i could dominate her on the
tennis court when she was 12 years old
but uh you know let's say a tennis
player
finds that they're always favoring their
forehand they try to make
make it so they always hit back with
their forehand here's an experiment
where they push the end bulb further for
themselves
why not play a game a serious game with
a friend of yours or whatever that
uh where you're always hitting with your
backhand so this is an experiment for
you
there's really no downside to it you
might still win the game
your worst case scenario is you lose a
game but
the the upside is that you get about
you you become one percent much more
well-rounded
as a player and your one experiment
makes you a better tennis player and so
all of these experiments so
whatever you're trying to get better at
let's say you'd like to get better at
sales
okay uh you know try to when
in your next sales meeting try different
techniques try being as quiet as
possible that's an experiment
try just asking questions of of the
client
or try asking him for or her for
advice so like uh you know
they ask you well what are you selling
me and instead of just responding like
anxiously here's what i'm selling i hope
you like it
just say well what do you need and i'll
tell you if i have anything like tr
get out of your comfort zone like that
could be very uncomfortable for many
people
or you know i always think in terms of
of games because that's a fun
area to experiment let's say you're a
very oh this is a this is a game that
happened to me once in
chess i was playing the us women's
champion
and i was winning this was when i was 18
years old
and i got so scared because she was
you know a strong player and i was
winning and i didn't want to blow it
i offered a draw and she instantly
accepted and then just walked away
and i did an experiment after that which
is i am never going to offer a draw
again
or at least for the next so many games
that i'm better at
and uh the experiment work the downside
is you might lose
some more games this year and
the downside is really not that bad it
costs you nothing and it makes you a
better
player because you'll you play more um
you'll be in more situations that are
stressful for you and you figure out how
to reduce that stress
how to increase your energy in those
situations and so on
yeah and it made me a better player so
just to remind people we're talking to
james altitude
on clubhouse simultaneously with
recording
for the release of his uh phenomenal
book which comes out tuesday
february 23rd which is when we'll
release this video uh
do me a favor and order this book
pre-order this book we want this book to
blow up this is james's greatest book
uh in history which is actually saying a
lot because you've changed you know
millions of people's lives james for for
the better uh you've changed my life
you've made me a better person a better
father better podcaster
and uh and uh not yet a better chess
player because you keep trying not
you and i will play one of these days
once i get my ranking above
uh the locker oh i'm happy to give you
uh a lesson so
one of the one of the techniques in the
book so in the book i list all these
techniques including
what i call the 10 000 experiment rule
but to be honest
it's more like a 200 experiment role i
really feel if you do about
200 experiments in whatever it is that
you're interested in getting better at
you'll be in the top 1 in in the world
and that's because by the way sorry to
interrupt you but that's because of your
other rule which is idea sex
so a hundred times a hundred is ten
thousand we talk in the book you talk in
the book
actually two hundred times two hundred
will get you ten thousand individual
unique
pairs of experiments or more than that
so actually yeah you're right you only
need the 100 by 100 to get a
10 000 of order 10 000 pairs which then
lead to this great blossoming
exponentially so in growth go ahead
yeah you know i never thought of it that
way but that's really true like look at
the greenland experiment for instance
that was a result of that's combining
my writing skills with you know the
research i did on greenland for this one
thing
with kickstarter so now i have i got
i didn't just get one percent better at
writing i got
one percent better at understanding
kicks so i got a lot better at
understanding kickstarter because those
initial experiments that you do with
something
are worth a lot more when you're in the
learning curve yeah and
i learned about an entire country which
is not really a country i found out
but uh that's one of the things i
learned and
uh but you know the other another
technique i have lots of
first off i appreciate you saying that
about skip the line that it's my best
book ever i think it is too because
this book has real it's not like a
bs self-help book it has real technique
everything is the technique that i've
used
and and people who have been on my
podcast including yourself have used to
become
top in their field and i mean and by
that i mean not just the skills
but monetizing because that's really
important it's one thing
to be in the sports space but it's
another thing
it's very difficult to monetize it and
uh
you know one of the techniques in the
book i talk about is a technique told to
me by
frank shamrock who was for 10 years like
the mma world champion
and it's called plus minus equal and
in um yeah that's where you get someone
to teach you
lessons it's it that's the plus the
equals is you use your peer group
to bounce ideas back and forth and the
minus is
you you're not really good at something
unless you can explain it simply unless
you can teach it
so obviously you know this as a
physicist
you had professors and teachers who
taught you
a lot that you know then you have peers
that you bounce ideas off of and of
course
scientists are also teachers and you you
have students so
a few months ago i decided to purely
test my ideas
by once again i haven't studied chess in
23 years
i've gotten a lot worse since my peak
and so i decided
i'm going to study the game using the
techniques
and skip the line i got myself a plus
i got myself equals and i got myself a
minus i'm giving some lessons out just
to have that minus
i completely switch the way i play so
i'm doing the 10 000 experiments
and i'm doing various uh you know i have
a technique called spoken wheel
in the book where you don't just do one
thing you do
many things in the area that you're
interested in so that
you see different angles of the subject
so in addition to
to playing i'm also you know streaming
it occasionally and then
doing other things so or or if if you're
interested in sports you could or if
you're interested in finance you could
do
write a book you could do a podcast you
could do a newsletter you could start a
hedge fund
those are different spokes of the same
right and
science it's important to do all of them
to become well-rounded
yeah and so many of the experiments that
you talk about really resonate with me
again it speaks to the quality of the
book and the
uh vision of the author that it can
apply i mean it's kind of weird that it
appeals so much to an experimental
astrophysicist
like me a humble one at that but you
know of course all the skills and i
followed you for
the better part of almost two decades
now or at least uh
15 years 14 years and that it resonates
with me and my audience you know who's
pretty nerdy and like me like to geek
out on physics this book
is uh is is replete with with
references and and kind of highlights of
some of the greatest names
in physics history and i want to talk to
about my friend who is very
my hero rather i i wish he'd be my
friend actually i'm doing an experiment
again inspired by you to create
artificial intelligent
galileo which i'm calling aio
and that will be part of of the spokes
system
supporting the the hub or the wheel
which is my galileo
homage in part going to be generated by
galileo's dialogue which is the book
that influenced me most as a scientist
influenced a man by the name of albert
einstein the most
and this book is one of the most
important books in human history and it
doesn't have an audio book
so no one's ever done an audio book in
the history of the world and i figured
uh
i'm going to do it uh but i need
permission i need to find out who owns
the rights to the translation i'm not
gonna translate it
uh and then you were just like just do
it just just do it
ask for you know permission later first
ask for forgiveness
which explains why i got how you go i
got you on clubhouse you didn't know i
was going to do this i figured oh if he
doesn't want to do it
i will uh i'll say sorry james i didn't
know it but it was an example i'm always
open for
i'm always open for a good experiment so
now james
yeah yeah about galileo just to finish
off about that so now i've got people
around the world
including one of the greatest physicists
alive today an italian by the name of
carlo rovelli
and he's offering to read a third of the
galileo's dialogue book
so much has attention as is getting that
if you go to
uh this that small site that sells your
book after you buy james's book
skip the line and all of his books uh
you will uh type in my name brian
keating
and it says it comes up brian keating
galileo in other words
they're already people are already
searching for this book there's a thirst
there's a hundred and i didn't write the
book
i'm just doing the experiment that you
commissioned me to do as my pi
so so and here's the interesting thing
it's not like you had to spend a year
during
doing the audio book before you conclude
if the experiment works or not
when i said okay just do it it probably
took you a few hours to find out
maybe even less to find out who had the
rights send them an email
get an email back and they said sure and
then
and then it just took you another couple
hours to think okay well it'd be
interesting if there's a a bunch of
different voices and
oh it can't hurt me to ask carlo rivelli
the the downside is he says no the
upside is
one of the most famous physicists in the
world reads the book in galileo's voice
and he's italian no less so uh
it probably just took you a couple hours
to set the stage
and guess what it's not one percent
improvement you're one of
you're considered one of the world's
experts on galileo now and you will be
even more so as
the book finishes and comes out so
that's the benefit of this
i did an experiment a few months ago um
i
suggested to a friend of mine uh
charlemagne the guy who has a
host the radio show uh the breakfast
club in new york he has like 10 million
listeners a day
i i suggested i i took me an hour or so
i outlined an idea for a book i thought
he should write
and it was an experiment to just send it
to him and say i don't need to be
involved
you should write this book on racism and
now he asked me to be involved i even
said no to that at first but then we
we agreed to work together on it and
march 31st
probably the the top book in the world
on on racism will be coming out
you know you know partly you know it's
by charlemagne
with me and uh these some of these
experiments if the upside happens
it could be huge if the downside happens
if the experiment doesn't work
you set up the experiment like i'm sure
you set up your science experiments
you set up the experiment so you've
learned fairly quickly
if it's if it's got merit if it's going
to work or not and then you can continue
the experiment more
exactly so you talk about galileo
specifically in the book you say
galileo didn't listen to the received
wisdom of thousands of years
of a guy by the name of aristotle you
know he he may be known to some of the
listeners out there
who said that heavier things fall faster
than lighter ones galileo decided to do
an experiment
to take this out he dropped the
apocryphally we think he dropped the
heavy object a light object off the
leaning tower of pisa whether or not he
did it
is almost less important than the idea
that he could do it
and you say in the book and skip the
line you say galileo's experiment met
all five criteria of a good experiment
it was easy it was low risk its
potential was
huge it hadn't been done before and no
matter what he would learn something
through this one
experiment not only did galileo overturn
2 000 years
of thinking correcting the knowledge of
aristotle who's considered unimpeachable
in his intelligence but he also became
known
as the father of modern physics the
scientific method
and the ten thousand experiments rule
catapulted him to the front of the line
it's just okay and yeah and if you think
about it
people probably said to him galileo are
you kidding me
aristotle you think in the past
1500 years somebody would have
questioned
one of the greatest minds in history
what makes you think you
after 2000 years is going to come up
with something new
and it took them over 15 minutes to do
that experiment
and so all the time people are being
told
told you can't many people and this is
not a critique of people but
many people are civilians they they you
know they have
responsibilities mortgage kids i do
as well and they want to meet those
responsibilities so they do
what they need to do to get by and and
so on
but when you're a scientist of yourself
and i'm not talking about life hacks but
if you're a scientist of yourself
and you want to get better at something
you have to get better skills and you
have to get better at understanding the
field that you're in
so you do experiments to do that like
again
the greenland experiment imagine writing
a whole novel
now that's that's a kickstarter that's
in kickstarter format
i did a little experiment to sort of say
that oh maybe this is interesting and it
did turn out to be interesting a lot of
people not only did people
start donating money but people were
saying oh this is unusual
what a weird thing to do a kickstarter
to raise a hundred million dollars to
buy a country
and it's well written so i even read you
know
met a different audience for my stuff
than than usual by doing a little
experiment
so all of these experiments have been
interesting there was one time
uh during the early stages of the
economic lockdown
i thought to myself well nobody's
wearing suits anymore
and i'm just wearing pajamas all day
long because by definition
they're the most comfortable clothes why
not wear them outside
and i started wearing pajamas on planes
i started doing stand-up comedy in
pajamas i started
going to other people's you know meeting
people for dinner in in pajamas
just to see maybe there's potential here
for to design
a cloth a clothing line something i've
never done before
that's outerwear but pajamas you know
idea sex a little bit
and it didn't really work out i didn't
really find people were that interested
in it
[Music]
you hedge you talk a lot about in this
book about risk management i want to go
there next
we on these large projects like the
simon's observatory like bicep 2 which i
talk about
extensively in losing the nobel prize we
deal with what are called risk
registers these are basically simple
probabilistic
estimates of both the likelihood of an
event occurring
uh the chilean peso will fluctuate to
our disadvantage against the us dollar
and since we pay labor
and concrete and gasoline instead of her
in chile where the telescope is located
17
200 feet above sea level uh that's a
risk that you know is known to have some
volatility it can happen
um there are other risks a global
pandemic can take place
uh my advisor father figure mentor can
commit suicide
uh these these are things that happen
and and
these are the things that are the you
know again the title of nicholas nassim
taleb's books
tells you everything they're all about
as you point out in this book i love
this book as like a meta-analysis of
nicholas tell uh
at one point but the black swans are the
most
impactful the hardest to predict how do
you maintain that
not i know you're not like a huge fan of
like resiliency and grit but rather
another one of his books anti-fragility
how do you deal with something like that
like my advisor committed suicide i was
in a deep depression
for months and and i can't you know
percolate down
god forbid someone that works with me
and sees me as a mentor or a father
figure
does something else so how do you deal
with those existential risks
which by almost by definition can't be
forecast
i mean first off i'm very sorry about
you know i remember reading that in the
book
in your book about losing the nobel
prize about your your mentor
uh committing suicide that's not quite
in the category of an experiment but
let's say an experiment doesn't work and
and
the looking at everything as an
experiment
um other than the life and death of of
peers and so on
but looking at everything you do as an
experiment helps you
to be anti-fragile so just to be clear
people think resiliency is the key to
success like you're persistent
despite things going bad but that's not
quite true
it's anti-fragility as nasim taleb
points out which is you become
stronger from failure not just resilient
from failure
and the whole idea is if you if you view
everything as an experiment
no matter what your worst case scenario
and experiment thing
it's like thomas edison said a reporter
asked him
what does it feel like to to fail 10 000
times when he tried to
make the first light bulb and he said i
didn't fail 10 000 times
i found out 10 000 ways not to make a
light bulb
and you you by viewing everything as an
experiment
you're able to say well this didn't work
out but what did i
learn from it because that's how you
move the one percent forward
if let's say i'll use chess as an
example
let's say you play a game of chess and
you lose i know people who
get so upset at themselves they throw
the pieces they're the sore losers
heck i've been like that i'm the i'm i'm
the person who threw the pieces i do
have to
wreck it at a chess board that's that's
how i come back i compound i do
idea sex with my anger but yeah it's uh
that that's violent idea sex but um
with with chess it's really important to
analyze your losses like oh i just lost
this is a great example to never lose
i'm gonna make sure i never lose like
this again so you study you spend
just five minutes ten minutes studying
the game then you turn on the computer
and you have the computer analyzed so
you study it again just just analyze it
twice
and you you will be literally one
percent better at chess for doing that
every time you really analyze one of
your games same thing with a business
same thing with a sale that didn't go
through same thing with
investing now here's here's the thing
about risk management
if you're doing something that
a lot of people love let's say you have
a passion so you're passionate about
writing or let's say you want to make
money
investing the rewards are there
people have made money through investing
for instance
we know that there are rewards in doing
this it's not like every investor
loses all their money but uh
since you know the rewards are there
your only job really
is it's about one percent reward 99 risk
because if you can stay in the game you
win the game
all you need to do is stay in the game
but
because the game is always changing and
people are the best players in the game
are always improving whether it's
investing
or science or writing or comedy or
whatever
you need to constantly be experimenting
and improving
like oh i i look look at warren
buffett's a great example
he's known as a value investor to be
honest he hasn't really done
value investing since 1960s or 70s he
has
many many styles of investing that he's
experimented with
don't forget this is the man who said he
who would net he said he would never buy
technology stocks he owns apple stock
his first
uh big tech investment was amazon he
lent them hundreds of millions of
dollars
so he was always willing to experiment
with things that he was
deeply uncomfortable with in order to
become the best
investor in the world and that's that's
really what you have to do
in comedy if you tell great jokes that's
fine
how about do how about now the
characters and your jokes
play around with doing different voices
for each one because guess what that's
louis ck experiment with that and those
are his funniest jokes now
all right so and that you know i look at
your book and i say
you know this this experiment that you
talk about with with
you know failing experiments you know
with whatever that means because it's
not even clear as you point out again
and again there's no like
since there's no one skill called
stand-up comedy
or astrophysicist or you know or you
know chess player or whatever
there's no one skill this is compendium
of micro skills you by definition can't
fail
because you are more than the sum of
those parts the combinatoric parts and
you talk about in the book
an experiment you did in twitter which
we're going to replicate in a few
minutes on
clubhouse so i am now repeating an
experiment you did
with the technology that was in its
infancy called twitter and i am now
doing it in clubhouse and i'm gonna do
another thing
uh which you did which is when you
reached out to costello
uh who was the um uh who is the ceo
early ceo
of of twitter and uh and he ended up
writing the forward to choose yourself
and you asked him you sent him all these
ideas well guess what we're gonna do
james you and i are gonna send ideas to
the ceo of clubhouse whoever the hell
that is
and see if we can get in on their early
evaluation round
we'll spread that money out amongst all
the people that are in this room as of
right now jay
take a screenshot whatever upside we get
we are going to spread out
one percent to those people 99 98
james and me but anyway you talk about
it and you say that um
you talk about one experiment change
your life forever even though it could
be viewed as a total failure
when you learn you earn every experiment
you learn from will allow you to skip
the line i thought about this
uh i did a quick you know this is one of
my experiments i did a quick google
search
if you take the words the best thing
that ever happened to me
if you just take those words and you ask
the following question of google
what two words precede that those five
words
most frequently in writing online in the
english language and you know what you
get
what two words i failed or like
i was fired and i talked about this in
losing the nobel prize getting fired
from the most prestigious university on
earth from stanford university
led me in direct fashion to skip
whatever lines would have been in my way
to having this conversation with you
to being married to my wife to having my
children i would not have had that had i
not been fired
and even though at the time i didn't
think it was the worst i was kind of
grateful to get fired
i didn't get along with the boss i was
working with at the time um
but uh but then things got put in motion
she helped me out i got set up and the
rest took care of itself through a lot
of hard work but that notion that
almost everybody james says you know of
a failure it was the best thing that
ever happened to me
and yet we fear failure why is it why is
it that we don't have that
panoptix synoptic view in the moment
that
shoot you know okay failure okay that's
part of it yeah it's gonna lead to it
why is it so hard to get over that
mental model of failure as
ultimate destruction it's a it's a
really great question because
because we know intellectually that
failure is a learning experience if you
ask anyone
they will say failure is a potential
learning experiment experience
but why do we fear it so much it's
because
you know we've been in modern society
for let's say
a couple hundred years you could even
argue a couple thousand years
but the human species has been around
for
two million years we and we haven't
really been evolving
that our brain has not evolved since
then our brain still thinks
we're in a tribe of 30 people at best
and when you fail it releases
a neurochemical that signals hey buddy
you might get kicked out of the tribe
and if you're kicked out of the tribe
you can't nobody can survive on their
own in the woods you're going to get
eaten by
a lion so that cortisol
is an immensely powerful neural chemical
it's like a drug in the system
oh hey james yeah so now you're talking
so we're talking about experiments that
we want to do
like you did with twitter and we want to
do these
um you know and then give clubhouse some
ideas for free
and then we'll see if we can make it
better so the first step is getting you
involved
getting you online and getting you some
followers that you'll have this
massive base you went from zero to 106
followers
uh instantaneously and you know james
it's interesting clubhouse it took me
two years to
earn uh you know 2 000 followers
on on twitter it probably took me two
years
or at least a year on youtube it took me
i i still just barely got above 2
000 on instagram i don't spend that much
time there but clubhouse it took me
literally james took me six days to get
to 2000 followers
there's something either happening in
twitter and it'll be interesting to get
your
viewpoint on it where they're
suppressing followers or something like
that
or there's something unique about
clubhouse that has this dramatic reach
what do you think it would be
do you think that like the other
platforms are censoring or something
else
uh yes i think i think um the algorithms
have gotten
very harsh like i noticed even when
somebody was tweeting the cover of my
book
it said may contain sensitive material
the cover of my book which is a very
innocent looking
cover so i don't know what what's up
with the twitter algorithm but
uh newer social media apps like
clubhouse and even tick tock
have much more sophisticated algorithms
about showing people
um other people that they might be
potentially interested in following
and they're very good at like very
quickly experimenting
in the algorithm almost like many focus
groups that take
seconds to see which people are
attracted to which type of people
yeah and they're constantly changing the
your the brian keating algorithm of who
you might be interested in
to make it better and better and it's
very simplistic same thing with tic toc
it's much more sophisticated than
instagram or twitter or facebook which
is why you might not even have a lot of
followers but be exposed to a lot of
content that you don't
follow and and to see they learn by by
seeing
who you're interested in who you spend
time with and so on right
so clubhouse could be doing that as well
but i would say
one experiment that people could do to
improve their clubhouse followers
is organize events so like
i'm thinking of doing uh a podcast
for 10 straight hours where i'm
convinced everyone has a story to tell
so instead of a podcast we interview
like
just famous people or whatever anybody
can just
sign up on clubhouse and i'll and i'll
do a 10 hour podcast and i'll interview
anybody who randomly raises their hand
on clubhouse and says hey
interview me and my the experiment a
little bit is
proving everyone has a story worthy of
telling
from any from the random person on the
street to the most famous person
ever and if i use clubhouse to do that
i'll get clubhouse followers yeah just
like how i used to do q and a's on
twitter
i was just going to say that yeah you
did a q a on twitter you're the first
real person to implement that
now i view clubhouses kind of like the
benefit over twitter is like you
shouldn't
i mean you shouldn't drive at all james
let's be honest you you're you're you
basically
are menace to society on the roads but
uh but you can use clubhouse on the road
it's perfectly safe it's just
you know put on hands-free mode and i've
done it while i was supposed to be
you know talking and interacting with my
children uh but you know there's only
one uh you know i've got i've got a
couple children so
you know there's uh there's plenty of
them to go around but but actually
thinking about clubhouse you know and
keeping it open as this two-way
communication first of all people i want
to give people a chance to speak to
james altucher
let's get some questions uh for james
here we have harvine
who i've known for a little while only
through all these people i've only met
you in clubhouse
uh so harveen you have any comments
questions camellia you have any comments
or questions for james altitude the one
and only
yes just a quick comment
on compounding i mean i i appreciate the
idea of standing on the shoulders of
giants
but you could be compounding mistakes
too so
i i i just think that in some areas just
departing from what's come before
yeah right well that's the nature of uh
constructing things as an experiment as
opposed to the ten thousand hour rule
which i'm simplifying ten thousand hour
rule but it's a lot about repetition
and just keep on repeating in action
until
while you get better at it but that
could be a way that you're repeating
bad habits experiments are something
that happens that you do in
in the in the world to see if the world
responds
the way you think it might and it either
will or it won't
so it's not really about uh
compounding bad habits it's about
learning the good and the bad
and you're going to do that from
experimenting because the real world is
going to give you the feedback
and that's that's very important so when
i wrote this
this a piece about greenland on
kickstarter
i was very i very quickly learned that
oh kickstarter doesn't like this
but the writing people thought it was an
interesting idea
and i learned about greenlit so there
wasn't really any bad habits
to learn i i just i did an experiment
that improved the way i understood a
topic or if i do an experiment in
uh stand-up comedy i know right away oh
i did this weird thing that i've never
seen a comedian do before it was an
experiment
the downside is i'm going to get booed
the upside is
people are going to laugh hysterically
and i find something
new that nobody's ever done and i did
i've done
experiments every single time i
performed some of them work right away
some of them are horrible and people
hate it
people think what the hell is this guy
doing on stage
and you learn really quickly so it's not
about habits as much as getting kind of
feedback from the world just like a
scientific experiment
if i want to find out what temperature
water turns
into steam it's not about learning a
habit i'm going to learn the exact
temperature of water turns into
from a liquid into uh get into steam
thanks so much james james just uh one
other quick question on
on on writing and selecting subjects to
write about say something
keeps your curiosity um and you know
writing about it would increase
people's insight into that problem um
and you have the time you know such as
parabolas right
um is there is there something that
would stop you from writing it like some
kind of externality
that would make yes
only only one thing though so again i
don't hit publish
unless i'm afraid of what people will
think of me
and so i don't mind hurting myself
in my writing but i will never uh write
something that hurts another person
so that's that's a rule the one rule
i've really stuck to over the past 20
years
but there's no topic off limits i
remember one time i did
an experiment on tech crutch which was
is a popular blog about silicon valley
it was
i would say five six years ago was the
most popular
blog about silicon valley and everybody
would write about apple
or google or these write these very
technical or dry
articles so i wrote an article about
my first business and my customer
and how i got the customer and so on but
then at the end
i just mentioned at the end of this
article that you had this
secretary who had a scar all the way
down the side of her face
and my last line was i wish i could i
wish just once i had
licked the scar right off her face not a
line you usually see
in a a a blog about entrepreneurship or
investing or business
and people were like what the hell did i
just read
but it was an experiment just to be a
little bit more
literary and appealing in a mostly dry
sort of blog and it worked really well
and i started doing all the time
i got at one point the ceo of aol
which owned techcrunch even called me
tim anderson and said
i always know when you're writing
because the patriots for the entire
cycle up uh let's see
camellia do you have any comments or
questions for james
yeah sure thank you i'd like to say
thanks james
so much for your last year's ij live
during lockdown because it encouraged me
to write my first
english novel and self-publish on amazon
thank you oh you're you're very welcome
and you know that
was a series of experiments so those ig
lives i had never done them before
and then i started converting them into
podcasts just and that was an experiment
and they did
even better than my usual podcast and
and then i encouraged people i i to
experiment with writing so i came up
with these sort of
book writing experiments where you can
write a book in a month
and i came up with very simple formulas
to write a very interesting what i
thought would be very interesting books
and hundreds of people ended up writing
their their first book so i'm really
glad
i'm really glad you were one of them
yeah thank you
i got a question about the creator
economy
as you know um maybe i mean
during lockdown a lot of individuals
they start to
like just work for themselves but do you
think in the future
there will be a creator economy
like companies invest on individuals on
the creator themselves
absolutely and you know that very
question
is fascinating because again this always
goes back to the fact that
questions are much more important than
answers you ask the question
because you don't really know the answer
and so the answer could lead
you down a a pathway that could generate
huge success
imagine let's just make it up let's just
brainstorm a little bit
imagine somebody graduates college
but uh can't pay back their student loan
debt which is a common occurrence
what if we set up an exchange where
10 of that individual's income
he sells or she sells on an exchange
uh for the next 20 years so i can people
investors can bid to own 10 of this
person's future income
and he or she states well i'm a lawyer
i'm going to do this this this i'm also
going to make these paintings and people
going to decide how much they're going
to spend
for 10 income and they and this this way
the person
could generate uh cash to start paying
back the student loan debt as opposed to
you know waiting over years of
work to pay back the student i like it i
like because then i will encourage more
people to go to college and that's
bolstering my salary
that's awesome when everything's coming
up brian
exactly but we're just a good way to
make too everybody does thinking they're
selfish now but also related to this
question
it's very interesting because creators
think
that they're that the only thing they
need to get good at is creating
so often writers will will write huge
novels and nobody will read them
or or entrepreneurs will have great
ideas but no one will invest
and because this is the real world
and i didn't want to just do again some
bs
self-help book that doesn't actually
work a very important chapter in this
book
is about persuasion because you have to
be able to persuade
others that your experiments and your
skill set and
things you create are interesting and
persuasion
i you know there are there are many
books about persuasion i've read them
they don't work like there's all these
techniques i've tried to
mirror mirror someone's actions and
they'll agree with everything you say
there's all these techniques i tried
that don't they don't work so i
specifically write about techniques
that have worked over and over for me
like magically
i've created literally millions of
dollars for me that i know work
every time and persuasion is such an
important part
of getting good at the field that you're
in
not just the skills of that field but
the but the practical aspects of
monetizing in that field so this is why
if someone if we if someone created a in
exchange for the creator economy where
people could invest in individuals
the individual has to be able to be
persuasive enough
that they are worth investing in so
that's why persuasion is an important
part of skipping the line
if i want to go on the stage at the
stand-up comedy club i have to somehow
persuade the booker
that i am a good risk if i'm a brand new
comedian
and and i'm not that's great you just
persuade me to buy a book
so let's say you're asking your boss for
a raise
and you're really nervous everybody's
nervous asking their boss for
me you go in and um
you say you want to raise your your
you've been working really hard you've
been doing a good job you want to raise
and the boss says i don't know we kind
of
we're not really giving a lot of raises
this year the economy is bad
you know well how much what kind of race
do you want
how much more money do you want here's
here's a great technique that i call the
advice technique
you say to the boss listen i've been
my head's down to the ground like i've
been working really hard
you're like the grand master at
negotiation
i've really respected you not just as a
boss but as a friend
so just pretend
um you're just helping me out i i need
your advice
since you're an expert in this how
should i ask you
for a raise yeah you're listening to
this jay jay you listening to this
yeah he's nodding he's nodding
uh you know the advice technique has
worked for me so much
even selling companies for millions of
dollars so an acquirer will say well how
much do you want for your business
and i say look i've been focused on
building the business
you bought a thousand companies i'm just
asking i want to
work with you i want to be acquired by
your company
you tell if we're gonna be partners give
me good advice what how should i think
about valuing my company
they're going to give you they're gonna
first they're gonna be happy you gave
them status
in that way second they're not gonna
give you bad advice because you just
told them
one of the reasons you admire them is
because they're an expert on this
they're gonna give you a good advice
and then if you follow their own advice
they're not gonna they're not gonna say
no after that
so the technique is like magic it works
every time
a zev uh zev is a physicist and he's
going back to school at age 47
james to get his phd in physics which
you are
you're working on as well and uh and the
correspondence course that i offer here
at ucsd
zev it was also zev's birthday he shares
a birthday this week with galileo
galilei
who we mentioned in skip the line is a
prominent figure
uh so have any questions for the man
who's reinvented himself
again and again and always uh never
fails to not
undo the effect of not failing to choose
himself
yeah um you know at 47
i'm 53 now at 47 i suddenly
decided i wanted to do stand-up comedy
and
you know among the other things that i
do and everyone told me
you can't do this it's going to take you
20 years you're going to be 67 before
you get on
stage and the more people told me i
can't couldn't do something
i i had to do it and i studied
every comedian i skipped the line a
little bit by having
um all great comedians on my podcast so
i could ask them
questions and interview them and
whatever happens to me the night before
on stage i would ask them on my podcast
the next day
and uh you know i essentially skipped
the line
i didn't care that people told me i
couldn't do it i knew i would be able to
do it and now i've been
touring all over the world i mean when
when there isn't an economic lockdown
and so i congratulations on
pursuing a passion at the age of 47.
no matter how many people told you you
can't do this but you think you're doing
it
yeah uh so first i would like to you
know i'm not famous with
my wife marina you probably know her
rina freeman was
and uh she's not on this oh yeah yeah
she interviewed robin
robin's first podcast ever was with uh
his wife is that
wife yeah yeah i've been on her podcast
yeah so i want to give credit to her and
oh she's there
you know i did this before when i was uh
25 years old i was
horrible high school and all that
relative said there's no way you'll get
into uc berkeley
for an undergraduate physics they're
really worried about me
and then i got accepted to uc berkeley
from undergrad and physics
completed that i got to graduate school
so i'm hoping i can make the same play
again you know and shock the world yeah
i mean
i can't uh but i'm doing it myself i
can't listen to what everyone else does
and
everyone that says no i mean when i for
i wanted to start a hedge fund
in 2003 and i asked my neighbor who was
in the business
you know can i can i do this would you
will you
invest some money with me and he's like
uh i don't know how to say this james
but you can't do this
you you have to go to get an mba then
work at goldman sachs for a while and
work at a big hedge
fund and then maybe if you have
something unique to offer
you can you can start uh uh investing
for other people and maybe start a hedge
fund
and i didn't i needed to make money i
didn't want to wait
so i i just i experimented with
different strategies
at the time not a lot of people were
doing what brian's friend jim simons
does which is
write computer software to analyze
statistically the stock markets
so i did that and it worked out very
well for me i kept track of all my
trading and stuff and i showed my track
record to hundreds of
people and out of hundreds of people 10
invested and i had a hedge fund so i
offered something unique
first which is the last part of what my
friend was telling me to do
rather than going to goldman sachs and
hedge funds i just read every book i
could do
programmed some software tested
thousands of ideas i did tons of
experiments some experiments worked
most didn't and the experiments that
worked got me in business
and then i sent emails to hundreds of
people saying i'm using
artificial intelligence and software
to model the markets this is my track
record can we at least meet
and then one out of 10 would meet and
one out of 10 of those would uh
would invest money with me and then so i
skipped the line i
had a hedge fund within a few months
arena's here hey rina do you want to say
hi to james wish him a happy pub day
coming up
he did on twitter hi rina hi i'm excited
to vote for you for president
yes i you know among you should run for
president
everybody listening to that go to
fbc.gov and run for president
that's the ultimate uh exercising your
civic responsibility right if
everyone should vote then everyone
should run you know
and and politics is like the essence of
persuasion skills unfortunately because
people
the very good persuaders often have no
backbone behind
or no real solidity behind what they're
persuading about
but uh you know i i what inspired me to
sign up at fxc.gov
was i was in this debate about whether
one should vote or not
and i saw that most people trying to
debate
were very poor at understanding
persuasion like
they would just start insulting me or
they would start uh
doing what's called a false equivalence
they would say well if you don't vote
then you're a racist
and and i was saying well i'm happy to
debate about racism
so this is a technique called labeling
what so what are we really you say what
are we really talking about here
are you are we talking about if voting
what voting means over the past 250
years and whether one should vote or not
or are we debating about racism because
i'm happy to do that
as well and uh but that wasn't what i
thought the debate was about
so labeling what somebody is doing is a
good way to
shut them up if they're not making any
sense
that's another technique in the most
powerful one uh timmy
you're up on this oh who is that that's
a real quick question
james what's your recommendation for us
who are not old enough to run for
president
but are still vehemently conscientiously
objecting
yeah i think i i think there's lots of
things you can do
um you can do again there's the whole
spoke and wheel of
content so let's say your wheel is
political objection
there's newsletters books podcasts
um there's working for a campaign
there's starting a new party and finding
someone
to run for that party and finding people
to donate to that party
that that sounds like an extreme but you
just it's okay to have
extremes also in this you know and many
people do the smallest thing which is
they just argue on twitter which is
totally useless
but uh uh i think
having it it was stunning to me in this
past election how
everybody there was only two menus
served and you had to order everything
on one menu or order everything on the
other menu
so for instance if you loved
hydroxychloroquine
it also somehow magically meant you were
in favor of lowering taxes and if you
hated high drops before aquin
you wanted to raise taxes the two things
aren't correlated but it was amazing
how all the republicans believe one way
and all democrats believe this
other way so why why isn't everybody
running for president
and then maybe there should be some
online way to vote for
any of thousands of candidates
potentially and everybody should be able
to express their views
so i'm also an objective
i'm an objector to the entire system not
as
an anarchist but just that everybody
should express
their opinions and i don't think enough
people do that
here's another experiment i like to do
argue
both sides of something so this is
called steel manning
your argument um um vehemently
pro-choice for instance but my business
partner
is religiously pro-life and
i steal man's my argument meaning i
could probably argue
the pro-life side better than he can so
when someone's if once you steal man an
argument
another great persuasion technique is
if their argument slips you can say
listen i hear what you're saying
but there's a better way to convince me
about your stance which is to do this
this and this
because i've been able to argue i'm able
to do that because i'm able to
argue their side better than they can
and that's an important technique that
most
political people never do
[Music]
i'm i have a question how on earth in
the middle of the pendant
uh were you able to write this book with
everything that you're going on
you're parenting with robin five kids um
you moved to florida just
how do you do it well
you you sort of make sure everything
requires energy
and you just have to make sure you
almost have to do an audit of how you
spend your energy
do you spend your energy worrying about
uh what relatives think about you do you
spend your energy worrying about
what parties you're invited to use your
energy worrying about
um is this a good business idea maybe i
should raise money for it
well try not raising money for it try to
start the idea
without raising money for a book what i
would do first is
this is what i do for every book is that
uh i find
lots of articles i've written i
literally staple them together
and that's a first that's that's a
zeroth draft it's not a book yet
but it looks like a book it's like 300
pages of words i've written
and then i rewrite everything and you
know a book goes through like 20 drafts
but that's a good way to start to give
you like energy and make you feel like
you're accomplishing things yeah
and then it's just a matter of you know
rewriting and
and honing different points but it was
hard because
before the lockdown i was five nights a
week performing
stand-up comedy which was taking a lot
of energy that's like five six hours a
night
and i was i was wasn't writing the book
like i should have been
so once i stopped spending energy on
comedy
because of the lockdown i was able to
write the book
and by the way now after all i've done
you know did hundreds of podcasts in
2020 i wrote
two books i did i started a business i
did other things after my new york city
is that article
i did get a little burnt out from all
the uh harsh reaction i got
in new york city i mean to have jerry
seinfeld trashing for an entire page in
the new york times
showed me that a my persuasion ability
was enough to rile him
up a little bit but b i just had so many
people angry at me
i got i got a little burnt out yeah i
turned that to my advantage i used that
to say okay i'm gonna use i'm gonna
experiment with my own book i'm gonna
use the skip the line techniques
to get better than i ever was at chess
even though i haven't studied it in
23 years and um right now i'm probably
right back at the peak of where i was in
the 90s
and now i got to push a little more to
get better but i'm there
so and i just use the techniques in the
book
super impressive you are just so amazing
and you your resiliency is
so inspiring and i'm i'm definitely
going to use your techniques
what do you think about james dean let
me know let me know how it goes when you
do
i will yeah we all got to support cam
and she's uh
she is one of the reasons i stay on
twitter cammy you can
mute your your volume but you do give me
hope that this platform
is can be used for good and convinced me
to use clubhouse along with jay
that you guys really show that there's a
good side to it uh
and and even my wife who's not on any
social media you know she
she gets mad when i'm on clubhouse and
james you'll you know i know you needed
another addiction so
that's why jay and i conspired to get
you on here uh but the bottom line is
it is addictive arena told me that yeah
go ahead
sorry it's a good addiction because
being burnt out and
rationalizing that i'm using the
skipping line techniques to get better
at chess
that that has become an addiction and i
need
i need another addiction to wean myself
off this one yeah and your needle drug
habit
uh but correct
the smoking crack piles exactly uh let's
see yossi you haven't said anything
uh yes if you have anything to add
you're up on stage so
uh hi i just like to give an example of
how i skipped the line and
chose myself maybe certain uh a bit of a
certain
certain difficulties however you
pronounce it um
first i've been following james for many
years i don't know 15 years or so oh
thank you
i uh i remember when you had a show with
steven dabner
oh yeah yeah back in the day so you
at that time you you i think maybe you
still do it but you had published your
cell phone number and you said you know
send me questions or maybe it wasn't
even before then ask them
i lost track but um you had done a
yeah you you know you speak a lot about
um
that credit card um metrics and
and and the credit score is a bs metric
yes and during that episode you actually
um you went to a commercial break and
you had a
credit card ad
credit card and i i texted you about it
and you called and
you actually phoned me and you called me
to tell me that uh
you're right that that this has slipped
through the crack somehow and
and and you do not believe in the in
what credit karma is selling
and you stood behind your opinion about
the whole credit rating system
so i just so so since then i i actually
had your cell phone number
and i when i got into clubhouse
it says who do you think would be a
great addition to cloudhouse
so i um you know i went through my
friends and they won't be such great
additions to clubhouse let's be honest
but who's who's a man who has a strong
voice and an
innovator so i figured hey james alton
show let me invite him
so yeah thank you so much for for
inviting me i think it was your invite
actually that
thank you and i was like i was like
there's no ways you didn't get an invite
from somebody else before
but now i i'm actually not on an
endanger rabbi so james you'd be
nominated by
dave rabbi
excellent and thank you so much and you
are part of the tribe and
james talks in the book about tribe
building so you uh
yossi is a member of the tribe and uh
james talk about tribe building that
people are always
the most suspicious of those they see as
the other a powerful strategy for
gaining rapport
and status is to find a common identity
with those you're dealing with
we call this try building and in any
situation
when where you know you're coming in at
a lower status or having
your status framed upon by somebody else
that can be used
either to your advantage or to your
disadvantage can you talk about try
building
yeah sure so so you know
i'll give an example um in in stand-up
comedy
so this is related to micro skills as
well as as brian was saying earlier
mo no there's no such thing as being
good in business
there's micro skills that make up the
meta skill of businesses sales
negotiation
execution persuasion and so on uh
same thing with stand-up comedy it's not
just humor it's likability it's crowd
work it's punch lines it's
storytelling it's stage it's stage work
as well as
it's mic work there's lots of uh
micro skills and tribe building is good
in
public speaking it's good in any kind of
event it's good for stand-up comedy
so here's how it works in stand-up
comedy you have to get the crowd
to like you otherwise they're not
they're not going to laugh
even if you're funny they're not going
to laugh if they hate you and if they
like you
they might laugh at things that aren't
funny so
one way to gain likability is to try
build
so let's say you know the there's one
part of the crowd
you say where are you from oh they're
from ontario or they're from paris
then there's a then there's a bunch that
was let's say that's a table of
women and there's a table of men oh
they're also comparison they're on the
other side of the
of the room you say hey you guys
exchange numbers you just start dating
each other maybe even tonight you can
have sex with each other you're both
you're all from paris or you could say
something else that kind of
relates them to each other um like you
know
is it true people in paris have a lot
more sex you guys
you know you ask each table to answer
and so now you've created a tribe across
the room of these parisians
who are laughing because you're
interacting with them and
they're in with you now they're in the
tribe with you i'm not very good at
socializing you know and i realized when
i
started moving down to florida everybody
here is friendly and wants to
socialize and they socialize it doesn't
matter what they do for a living i
suppose new york city where very much
matters
when you socialize and they can
socialize for 10 straight hours at a
time this is very difficult for me
so i try build by finding
and 60 of the people in south florida
are hispanic
so i find these games card games that
are played in south america
and i learned them and studied them and
got good at them
and i couldn't suggest now hey let's
play this peruvian card game morocco
next time we hang out
and they're all like oh you know barack
oh great let's do that
and so now now i can socialize for 10
hours because
i love playing games so i tried though
you did yeah so
james i know you got to go into another
international interview with the
international space station
but i do want to take a question from
rehab
uh which is uh something we've all uh
been noticing there you are rehab can is
that how you pass your name or hab
exactly thank you so much of course i
used to be a huge fan of you following
you and kura
what happened i don't i haven't been
seeing your you answering questions
because
like that's the fake i like to read more
than listen to me completely honest
so i haven't been seeing your posts
lately yeah i i love por i think
that's that's one of my favorite social
media sites or using it for years
and just to be honest i just in the past
few months i've gotten them
a little burnt out i think i probably
overdid it this year and then
i have never experienced as much
antagonism as i did from this one
article that i wrote
and i decided to just take a few months
off from all social media
and uh you know quora i
probably took a little longer time off
uh from that but
you're right i should get back into that
so i will
well james i want to uh thank you so
much not only for
uh for your you know time that you've
devoted to us today
for joining clubhouse and now millions
of people can interact with you
live as i've had the privilege of doing
i want to wish you all the best with the
best book that you've written
in my that could be a backpack you're
doing this it could be a backhanded
compliment activity
it's your best book okay well that's
that's okay you know
but uh but it is also one of the best
books i've read it actually
the end i'm gonna i'm going to leave the
biggest cliffhanger
i needed a box of tissues at the end i
don't cry very easily james
i'm a manly man as you know uh from
having tried to lift me up in person
once
uh but the uh but i want to thank you
for all the gifts that you've given to
the world
and this one especially i want to wish
you uh
and uh all the good stuff in the world
for this wonderful book everybody please
not only follow james on clubhouse
follow jay follow cammy
follow everybody up on stage everyone in
there i'm gonna follow everybody i don't
care
what people think about that james thank
you so much
all right everybody thank you so much
bye guys
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
[Music]
magic
[Music]
you